every time a court rules in favor of a  chick having a hundred thousand dollars  a month that puts men off to a level  like it's fine if there was a baseline  child support thousand dollars a month  two thousand dollars a month that's if  you have a kid Baseline regardless of  income if your man wants to give you  more he does if he does whatever  whatever but when you come along start  saying this percent of a man's income do  you have an idea how scary that is to a  man who works for his money he works for  his money and you know why it's scary  it's not just because he's giving his  money away it's because he knows he  isn't giving money to the kid yeah the  kid you could raise a kid on 500 bucks a  month in most of the world you want that  kidding Gucci you and Gucci you in a  nice car going on dates with another  dude with my money you could I'd rather  burn the [ __ ] house down and give a  200.